- [Voiceover] So pause
the video and see if you
can solve for x here.
Figure out which x-values
will satisfy this equation.
All right, let's work through this.
So, the way I'm gonna do
this is I'm gonna isolate
the x plus three squared on one side
and the best way to do that
is to add four to both sides.
So, adding four to both sides
will get rid of this
four, subtracting four,
this negative four on the left-hand side.
And so we're just left
with x plus three squared.
X plus three squared.
And on the right-hand
side I'm just gonna have
zero plus four.
So, x plus three squared is equal to four.
And so now, I could take the square root
of both sides and, or, another
way of thinking about it,
if I have something-squared equaling four,
I could say that that something needs
to either be positive or negative two.
So, one way of thinking about it is,
I'm saying that x plus
three is going to be equal
to the plus or minus
square root of that four.
And hopefully this makes
intuitive sense for you.
If something-squared is equal to four,
that means that the something,
that means that this
something right over here,
is going to be equal to the
positive square root of four
or the negative square root of four.
Or it's gonna be equal to
positive or negative two.
And so we could write
that x plus three could
be equal to positive two
or x plus three could be
equal to negative two.
Notice, if x plus three was positive two,
two-squared is equal to four.
If x plus three was negative two,
negative two-squared is equal to four.
So, either of these would
satisfy our equation.
So, if x plus three is
equal to two, we could just
subtract three from both
sides to solve for x
and we're left with x is
equal to negative one.
Or, over here we could subtract three
from both sides to solve for x.
So, or, x is equal to
negative two minus three
is negative five.
So, those are the two possible solutions
and you can verify that.
Take these x-values,
substitute it back in,
and then you can see when
you substitute it back in
if you substitute x equals negative one,
then x plus three is equal to two,
two-squared is four, minus four is zero.
And when x is equal to negative five,
negative five plus three is negative two,
squared is positive four, minus
four is also equal to zero.
So, these are the two possible x-values
that satisfy the equation.
Now let's do another one
that's presented to us
in a slightly different way.
So, we are told that f of x is
equal to x minus two squared
minus nine.
And then we're asked at what x-values
does the graph of y equals
f of x intersect the x-axis.
So, if I'm just generally
talking about some graph,
so I'm not necessarily gonna
draw that y equals f of x.
So if I'm just, so that's our
y-axis, this is our x-axis.
And so if I just have the
graph of some function.
If I have the graph of some function
that looks something like that.
Let's say that the y is
equal to some other function,
not necessarily this f of x.
Y is equal to g of x.
The x-values where you intersect,
where you intersect the x-axis.
Well, in order to intersect the x-axis,
y must be equal to zero.
So, y is equal to zero there.
Notice our y-coordinate
at either of those points
are going to be equal to zero.
And that means that our
function is equal to zero.
So, figuring out the
x-values where the graph
of y equals f of x intersects the x-axis,
this is equivalent to saying,
"For what x-values does
f of x equal zero?"
So we could just say,
"For what x-values does
this thing right over here
"equal zero?"
So, let me just write that down.
So we could rewrite this as x,
x minus two squared
minus nine equals zero.
We could add nine to both
sides and so we could get
x minus two squared is equal to nine.
And just like we saw before, that means
that x minus two is equal to the positive
or negative square root of nine.
So, we could say x minus two
is equal to positive three
or x minus two is equal to negative three.
Well, you add two to both sides of this,
you get x is equal to five,
or x is equal to, if we
add two to both sides
of this equation, you'll get
x is equal to negative one.
And you can verify that.
If x is equal to five,
five minus two is three,
squared is nine, minus nine is zero.
So, the point five comma zero
is going to be on this graph.
And also, if x is equal to negative one,
negative one minus two, negative three.
Squared is positive
nine, minus nine is zero.
So, also the point negative one comma zero
is on this graph.
So those are the points where,
those are the x-values where the function
intersects the x-axis.